[Music]
by now we know the time pushes the
envelope for every new mission
impossible right but in this exclusive
behind the scenes look at fallout while
it's clear the towns may have outdone
himself it's definitely a new mission
it's a big emotional entertaining story
with this one Tom's really doubled down
on this done aspect of risking his life
literally for the movie what the hell is
he doing okay
these exclusive images of Tom's
death-defying stunts to have our
adrenaline pumping people talk about the
action but what they're responding to is
their investment of the characters sure
it is Tom but seriously it's hard not to
look at this helicopter shot and wonder
how do you do that especially after Tom
told us chopper stunts are even more
dangerous to do than airplane stunts
there's an airplane at least you know
where the wing is stalling and it's you
know and and you have time to recover
most of the time with the helicopter
there isn't it's you don't stall a
helicopter it's it's either flying or
it's not flying and then when it's not
flying there is no recovery
three years in the making mission
impossible fallout is Tom's most
ambitious film of the franchise yet
bitter out and this is the best mission
yet
it's the tougher mission at the end you
always feel
[Music]